- [Instructor] In the last
video, we began discussing
some of the similarities and differences
between the English colonists
who landed at New England
versus those who landed in Virginia.
Thanks to different reasons
for migrating to the New World
and a much colder, rockier environment,
New England society was based
around mostly small farming
and led by the Puritan church.
Another consequence of
the unique environment
and society of New England was that
it was unusually democratic for that era.
Now, when the pilgrims first
came over on the Mayflower,
they agreed in what was
called the Mayflower Compact
to kind of work together
and hold each other in mutual esteem.
And some people say that
this is one of the first
founding documents showing
democracy in the New World.
New Englanders, like Virginians,
were very far from the mother country
and they had to fend for themselves.
So, English colonists learned
to make decisions by themselves,
'cause asking for help
from across the ocean
wasn't very easy and
took a really long time.
So, because England was so far away
and really not paying much attention
to the American colonies at all,
there was a tradition of self-government
among English colonists.
But what was different about
democracy in New England
than democracy in Virginia
was that most people in New
England were middle class.
They were small farmers.
Most people were about
the same social station
and that meant that they were used
to having about the same
amount of political power.
So, in New England, most
towns had town meetings
where the men of the town would gather
to solve local problems.
Now, this was, of course,
a very limited democracy
where only white men have a say,
but for the era of the 1600s,
it was very democratic indeed.
For all the ways that New England
and Virginia were very different,
there was one way in which
they were virtually identical
and that was their treatment
of Native Americans.
Just as early compromise and cooperation
with the Powhatan tribe
turned into the English
attempting to eradicate Native Americans
from the eastern seaboard,
New Englanders originally cooperated
with local Algonquian
tribes like the Wampanoags
or Narragansett Indians.
But as English demands for
more land and more food
began to disrupt Native ways
of life, relationships soured
and cultural misunderstandings
between the two groups
soon led to outright war.
When English settlers made
treaties with Native Americans
asking for land, Native
Americans thought that they
were asking for the rights
to hunt on that land,
not the rights to fence in that land
and not allow Native Americans on it.
So, because English ideas
of property did not align
with Native ideas of property,
soon, when Native Americans went to hunt
on their traditional lands,
they found the English
prosecuting them as intruders.
And because Algonquians
practiced Three Sisters farming
where corn, beans, and
squash were grown together,
English people, who
separated all their crops,
didn't recognize that those fields
were actually Native agriculture
and allowed their cattle and
pigs to roam through them,
destroying Native crops.
With so much pressure
on their source of food,
Native people began to
lash out at English people
who thought of themselves as the victims
of senseless Indian attacks.
By 1675, many tribes in the area
decided to work together
to oust the English
led by a man named Metacom.
In fact, I think Metacom
was only one of the leaders,
but the English called him King Phillip
and believed that he was
the instigator of this war.
So, in 1675, Metacom and other groups
began to attack English villages.
But in 1676, the English recruited
Indian allies of their
own and turned the tide,
so that by the end of 1676,
about 3,000 Native Americans had died
to about 1,000 English.
And those that were remaining,
the English either executed
or sold into slavery.
So, in this way, they
were not very different
from the English people
of Virginia at all.
Metacom's war, like the
Anglo-Powhatan Wars in Virginia,
really marked the end of
Native American resistance
to English colonization on the east coast.
Survivors fled further inland or north
and joined other tribes that continued
to resist the English
for many decades to come.
I wanna finish by just briefly summarizing
some of the similarities and differences
between English settlement in New England
and English settlement
in the Chesapeake Bay
that we've been talking about
throughout these videos.
Here, I've just made a quick chart
comparing some of the aspects
that we've talked about,
and, as I see it, there
are three real differences
between New England and the Chesapeake,
and two real similarities.
Now, one thing that was
really different between them
was just their environment.
New England was far
north of the Chesapeake,
so it was much colder and rockier,
which didn't permit the
settlers of New England
to conduct plantation
agriculture at a large scale
like we did in the Chesapeake.
So, instead, they had small
family farms, they fished.
Compared to the Chesapeake Bay
where although it was very hot and marshy,
not a healthy environment at all,
it was, with its very
long growing seasons,
a great place for plantation agriculture,
particularly growing tobacco.
Another major difference
between the two regions
was who came to each of
these places and why.
In New England, settlers
came for religious freedom
for the most part.
Puritans attempting to
escape persecution in England
hoped that they could set up
their Puritan city on a hill
in Massachusetts Bay.
So, consequently, they
were middle class families
who came as a family unit.
They had a lot more women in New England
than they did in the Chesapeake,
which meant that their
natural rate of growth
was going to be higher,
because they could have more families
and more families could
have more children.
In the Chesapeake, by contrast,
most settlers were single men
who were coming to seek their fortune,
either white men, often
as indentured servants,
or enslaved Africans who were forced
to migrate to the Chesapeake Bay
to labor in tobacco plantations.
So, there were fewer women
and the kind of rate of population growth
really only depended on more
and more people immigrating
as the unhealthy environment
led to quite a bit of death
from tropical disease.
The last major difference I see
is in the labor systems
of each of these regions
and the kinds of class
systems that they generated.
In the Chesapeake Bay, as
a group of early planters
became more and more prosperous
and brought in more and
more enslaved laborers,
there was a great disparity of wealth,
as the poorest were at the
bottom of the social hierarchy,
including enslaved people,
indentured servants,
a few small farmers who were
independent and had made it,
and then, at the very
top, the tobacco planters
who held most of the
wealth, but made up, really,
quite a small percentage
of the population.
In comparison, people in New England
had a general equality of wealth,
meaning that most people
were small farmers
getting by comfortably.
There weren't many people who were
at a distant top of the social hierarchy
and not that many people who
were stuck at the very bottom.
Most people in New
England were middle class,
but there were some similarities
between New England and the Chesapeake.
In both of these regions,
local government was unusually
democratic for the era.
In New England, the citizens of a town
would meet in town meetings
to discuss local issues
and pretty much all white men
had a say in those meetings.
In the Chesapeake, there
were also local assemblies
like the House of Burgesses in Virginia.
And although most of these
democratic institutions
were dominated by elites,
these elected assemblies
were still considerably
more democratic than
the monarchy of England.
And the last way that New
England and the Chesapeake
were quite similar to each other
were in their attitudes
toward Native Americans.
In both New England and the Chesapeake,
the English carried on wars of extinction
against local Native American tribes,
whether it was the
Wampanoags in Metacom's war,
or the Powhatans in the
Anglo-Powhatan Wars.
English colonists simply
could not imagine a world
in which they coexisted
peacefully with Native Americans
or in any way incorporated
them into their societies.
Now, I started this video
series with a question
about who was the real
spiritual ancestor of the United States.
Was it the New England
colonies with their pilgrims
and search for religious freedom,
or was it the Chesapeake colonies
with their search to find fortune?
Well, perhaps the evidence
that we've taken a look at here
has persuaded you one way or another,
but myself, I think, that
comparing the two of them,
we can see that, in many ways,
English colonization was directly impacted
by the environment and by the individuals
who came to each of these settlements.
But there are some larger
trends about English settlement.
In both the cases of
the New England colonies
and the Chesapeake colonies,
English people who came to the New World
had unusually democratic
forms of government.
They were independent, used
to taking care of themselves,
but they were also united
with their approach
to Native Americans.
Unlike the Spanish, who incorporated
Native Americans into society,
even if at the lowest rungs,
and the French or the Dutch,
who cooperated very much
with Native Americans,
English people saw Native
Americans as an obstacle
and one that needed to be removed.